my name is benji and i'm one of the core
contributors to pants which is
an open source build system
and today we're going to talk about
python code based architecture and
specifically
about mono repos
and i know that this is a controversial
uh topic on which there are many
opinions i am going to present mine and
i fully acknowledge that there are
others
um
a little about me and uh
why it is that i came to have a lot of
strong opinions here
i've worked as a software engineer for
many years i
have had the good fortune to work at
some really great companies
and as i mentioned i'm a maintainer of
the pants open source
developer workflow system and in the
last couple of years i have been a
co-founder of tool chain which is a
startup in the
developer tools space
so
a quick overview of this talk basically
three parts uh i'll start by defining
terms what is a monorepo what do i mean
when i use that term
uh a
bulk of the talk will be well what why
would i want one um
and the last part of the talk will be
about um
say you're on board with wanting a
monorepo what kind of tooling makes
working in a monorepo effective
so let's jump right in to
what is a monorepo
so
there is one thing that is a common
characteristic of
kind of basically every code base almost
all code bases that any of us are
working on and that is that they grow
over time
and they grow because
you have some set of developers that are
adding code over time but also if you're
hiring and your team is growing then
you're adding more developers who are
adding code over time and so your code
base can grow uh faster than linearly
over time
and
there is a very common consequence to
this
which is that builds uh get slower and
less manageable they become unstable
they become
unbearably uh slow and clunky
now i can already hear
the objection forming in some people's
minds what do you mean by builds python
is not a compiled language so i'm using
the term build and if you don't like the
term build you can substitute developer
workflow in the general sense so it's
every step that you take from when you
hit save in your editor to having an
artifact that's ready to deploy so for
example resolving and downloading your
external dependencies or generating code
or type checking or running tests
obviously is a big one
debugging in a repel linting formatting
actually building and packaging those
deployable artifacts python definitely
has a build it just doesn't have a build
time compiler
so that's what i mean by build
and again these all of these get slower
and less manageable as your code base
grows
so what do we do
as your organization and your code base
grows we have
basically two architectural alternatives
to how to manage that code base in a
scalable way
and those two are the multi-repo
architecture versus the monorepo
architecture and i should mention that
obviously this is a continuum you don't
have to be at the extreme end of either
of them
but generally this is these are the two
poles through which this continuum goes
now let's start by talking about
multi-repo
multi-repo means as your code base grows
you actually
split it up into a growing number of
small or you know manageable size repos
and typically you split them along team
boundaries or project boundaries or
library boundaries
and very often
this kind of happens naturally because
it's the path of least resistance the
easiest way to get a handle on scale is
to just take an axe to your code base
and just carve it up somehow and worry
about the consequences later and we will
obviously talk about those consequences
soon
but there is an alternative
and the alternative is
what i refer to as a monorepo
and the monorepo is you keep a single
unified growing code base that contains
code for multiple projects multiple
services
that share underlying dependencies and
tooling and best practices
now a monorepo for example may contain
code for multiple in multiple languages
or even in the same language it may
contain code
relating to multiple frameworks and
typically you'll have different parts of
your team working on different but
overlapping parts of the monorepo very
often they will overlap on exactly those
shared dependencies
and as your code base grows as your
organization grows your single unified
monorepo grows along with them
now i should emphasize
that um
we are talking about codebase
architecture not deployment architecture
so a monorepo is a as an architecture is
agnostic to whether you deploy
you know a few large monoliths or you
deploy many microservices and in fact
there are often many advantages to
deploying microservices out of a
monorepo because when you have a great
many services they have to
they share dependencies and in
particular they often share
protocols
because that's how they talk to each
other and so it is often very helpful to
have those be in the same repo
and that leads me on to the second part
of this talk which is okay
monorepo defined
why should i want one
and
i will freely admit that multi-repo does
sound better at first
it's
more decentralized uh it allows you to
make local decisions um
you can sort of do your own thing uh in
your monorepo you can put a boundary
around it and
sort of
maintain order uh in your repo and keep
all the barbarians from from other parts
of your team out of your code
it sounds good and these are good
buzzwords uh and there are cases when i
think that is actually valid um i'm not
um
a total fanatic here
but there are a set there is a set of
core problems in code based management
that multirepo
not only doesn't solve but it hides them
it obscures the problems until you
encounter them down the line whereas a
monorepo makes these problems explicit
so you can reason about them
and there are various ways to convince
yourself of this um
because of shortness of time i've boiled
it down to
uh really one main
point that i want to make which is that
from my experience the hardest code
based problems are
managing changes
and managing dependencies
and the overlap the intersection of
these two is particularly tricky it is
where so much of the pain
of codebase management
lives and to the extent that we can pick
a code based architecture that makes
handling these problems easier i would
argue that we should consider doing that
so when we think about managing changes
um in a world of dependencies
or managing dependencies in a world of
changes
let's look at first how these challenges
are handled in a multi-repo world so
multi-repo relies on publishing
so if you have a bunch of repos and you
know some of them consume some code some
library or some utility from repo a
it has to publish an artifact say in
python that would be an estus or a wheel
or whatever now when i say publishing
this could mean to a private internal uh
corporate repository not necessarily to
public pipi because remember that we're
talking about an organization's internal
code base here
so we rely on publishing
but
unless
repo a never changes which i mean let's
be realistic here it will
it's not just that you need to publish
but the artifacts you publish need a
versioning scheme
so
when you make a change or someone makes
a change to this repo a they have to
republish that under a new version
and why because otherwise those changes
might break the existing consumers of
repo a at the old version
so if you know to look at a more
specific example here if we have repo b
that depends on repo a it does so add a
specific version
so now say you're an engineer working in
repo b
and you need some change to this
upstream dependency
so
first you have the organizational task
of finding out who owns a repo a
are you know figuring out are you even
empowered to make a change in replay but
let's say that you are or you've
convinced the owner to make the change
that has to be
published
under a new version and then you need to
consume that new version presumably in a
new version of your repo and now
something needs to happen and you have
two choices
when it comes to
change management through these
dependencies
so first of all you can decide to be a
good citizen and make the virtuous
choice the virtuous choice is you find
all the other consumers of repo a that
could be many
you ensure that their code still works
with your change
you modify those repos as necessary
until say their test faster until you've
figured qualified that your change is
good for them
and that is a lot of work uh because
first of all how do you know who all the
consumers of repo a even are remember
that uh dependency consumption metadata
lives on the consuming side so repo a
there's no metadata in repo a that says
here is the universe of
my
of other repos that depend on me so you
have to find them somehow then you have
to figure out well how do i
test the change what do i know enough
about this repo to even
run its tests or
you know figure out how to qualify that
this
change is good
but let's say i figured all that out and
i've done it
um
i'm still not done because i actually
have to do this recursively if i made
any changes to the direct consumers of a
so repos you know sure i made changes to
b because that was why i started this
whole uh
laborious piece of work but say there's
you know c d and e that also depend on a
if i've made any changes there then i
have to recurse this process and i have
to find all the consumers of those
libraries or those repos and do the
whole thing over again this is a
tremendous uh there's a lot of friction
here it's a tremendous amount of work
so
even though um
you know being a good citizen is good
but very often you end up making the i
would call it the lazy choice which is
i'm not even going to worry about the
other consumers of repo a because that's
what versioning is for right they're
safely pinned to that earlier version
and when those other consumers need to
upgrade i will let them deal with that
problem
but
this isn't very nice
because by the time
they have to do that upgrade
they may have no context for your change
you may have lost context for your
change maybe you're not around anymore
so essentially what you've caused is
you know the problem famously known as
dependency hell
um you you've effectively
caused these other repos potentially
you've caused a dependency resolution
problem where if they don't upgrade but
they depend on a through two different
paths they may end up with two different
versions which is impossible like one of
them has to be picked and it's possible
that neither of them will work and this
is exactly what i meant by
hide the multi-repo hides problems it
allows you to essentially push
responsibilities off onto other people
at a future time so you've left a little
time bomb in the code base
and that is not a great way to be
part of a productive and cohesive team
so that was multi-repo
but in a monorepo there's no versioning
or publishing
all the consumers
uh again we're talking about a continuum
but in the extreme case at least all the
consumers are right there in the same
repo you can find them using like rip
grep or whatever your you know code
based comprehension uh utility of choice
is uh you can run all the tests you can
run all the tests in the reaper you can
run just the relevant tests if you have
the right tooling to do that to ensure
that your changes are good
and
any breakages are immediately visible
you're essentially making self-contained
changes that are guaranteed if you are
scrupulous about running tests and so on
they guarantee to be good at head
like you are keeping everything in
lockstep
um and so you can see an example here a
really important one in my opinion of
how code-based architecture actually
enforces good teamwork and
responsibility
so more generally this was a big example
i would argue that
even though it seems counterintuitive
monorepos can often be more flexible
than the alternative so for example they
are easier to refactor
they're easier to debug because you can
transit easily through all the sources
that uh
affect your the the
code under debugging
you have unified change history so it is
very easy to reason about
the mutation of the code over time it's
easier to discover and reuse code
because everything's right there in this
single repo putting repo boundaries
between different parts of your code
base
reduces flexibility
and my last point here and more
generally is that
i have found
i have seen from experience without
naming names that
the code-based architecture is very
often a reflection of
the structure and functionality of your
organization
so
there are many cases where localized
decisions and creative chaos are
desirable sort of wisdom of crowds type
things
but an engineering organization
is not a bottom-up kind of thing like by
its very name and nature it's organized
and in a well-functioning engineering
team priorities and decisions and effort
allocation flow
top down and some sort of top-down
organization is required and in
engineering organizations code base
very often reflects those organizing
principles and i think this is why
many large companies
you know google facebook twitter many
others have adopted this monorepo
architecture
because it helps keeps the organization
unified even when they're a huge huge
scale
so that's kind of what i had to say
about my sort of advocacy in favor of uh
mono repos for python and in general
but focusing a little bit on python i
did want to
for the remainder of this talk about
tooling for a python monorepo so
we are
accepting that we if for the sake of
argument we've accepted that we want a
monorepo how do we work in one
effectively
so
the observation is that standard python
tools the tools that you all use every
day from pi test to pip to my pie to
flake eight you name it
generally are not really designed for uh
monorepo architecture
typically they rely on uh the reasons
are that they rely on global state
and they rely on sort of side effecting
into the file system they they leave
virtual ends and files all over the
place and they're expected to be there
when you need them
and
as a result
small changes tend to trigger full
reruns of of whatever task it is you're
doing whether it's running tests or
running um
i don't know my pi for type checking
uh linters formatters you tend to sort
of run them universally um the tools
generally are designed to expect that
they run on an entire
package hierarchy on an entire repo now
some individual tools may have special
case mitigations for some of these
issues but it's very ad hoc so typically
when you end up using when you use these
teams these tools sort of naively in a
growing monorepo environment they do a
lot of repeated work
and that slows things down so how do we
speed things up
really
there are two ways to speed up work
there's one is do less of it and the
other is do more of it concurrently
to do less work uh in this context of
developer workflows you really need two
feet two important features you need
fine-grained invalidation namely the
ability to
analyze it at a pretty fine grain what
the effects of changes are
and caching so that if work has been
done before you don't have to do it
again done by you or potentially done by
someone else on your team if you have
shared
remote caching
when it comes to doing more work at once
first of all you need to be able to
reason about concurrency you need some
system that can say
these pieces of work are allowed to run
at the same time they can run
concurrently because they don't one does
not depend on the output of the other
and you want to at least have support
for remote execution so that
instead of concurrency being limited to
the number of cores on your laptop or on
your ci machine you could potentially
have dozens or hundreds of cores working
for you at the same time
so what kind of tooling has these
features
um
to work effectively in a monorepo
unsurprisingly you need a build system
designed for that
now these build systems
or more generally developer workflow
systems don't reinvent the wheel for the
most part um you want one that sits on
top of existing standard tooling
but it orchestrates them for you it
figures out when to run which one and on
which inputs
and so these tools
tend to be very different from things
like make or talks or running the
underlying tools directly like literally
just running pi tests directly on the
command line and there are good reasons
for those differences and we will get
into some of them
so
fortunately such tools exist
here are some examples of them um
i
and there are several others
now i am
freely declaring my bias here as i
mentioned one of the core contributors
to pants and have been for many years
through two uh major rewrites of it so
i'm naturally biased towards it uh but i
will mention to back up that bias for
this audience that pants was uh the most
recent iteration of pants that we
launched last year was specifically
designed with python use cases in mind
so it's not tacked on to a c plus
system it is we designed for python uh
but i each of these systems has their
strengths and they tend to work in
similar ways if you squint which is uh
what i will
go into for the remainder of the talk
so there are many interesting aspects to
these tools um i'm going to look at
three that kind of
to me stand out and what makes them
different from
other types of tools you might be
familiar with
and the three are um that they have a
goal-based command interface
that they rely on bill graph metadata
and that they implement a workflow that
has no side effects and relies on no
side effects and that you can extend
with custom logic and i will now go into
what i mean by all of this
so
um
let's start with the what i refer to as
a goal-based command
interface
so with a monorepo build system
you don't say you know run pip on this
or run pi test instead you specify i
want to achieve a goal and these goals
are generic verbs like test or package
or lint
and the system translates that into uh
execution of underlying tools like pi
test setup tools pylon flake 8 whatever
my pi whatever tests whatever tools
are necessary here
this is important for a couple of
reasons one is um
to support uh invest it's necessary to
support invalidation and caching like
you need a conceptual layer between what
the user wants to achieve and the
expensive part which is actually running
processes because maybe you don't need
to run a process maybe uh
you can resolve uh get a result from
cash or maybe uh you don't you know you
only need to run it on some subset of
files so you let the system figure that
all out for you and so you can see some
examples here of the types of command
lines you can run you can say run on
this file you can run on this global
files you can run on just files that
have changed in uh git since uh this tag
that kind of thing
so that's what i mean by uh goals
the next point i mentioned was
the build graph the idea of this code
dependencies
so
monorepo build systems need
extra metadata to figure out sort of the
packages and the dependencies between
them and like what the structure of your
code is some tools require this to be
very explicit and handwritten uh and
other tools and pants included can infer
this metadata by looking at import
statements and other aspects of your
code
and having this data allows the tools to
do fine-grained invalidation so if a
file changes
we know
which transitive dependencies are
affected so now we know for example
which tests might need to be rerun and
which tests can be skipped or resolved
from cache
and another example of how this data is
used is the system knows
which internal and external dependencies
need to be packaged into your deployable
binary because in a monorepo you may
have multiple binaries that you're
deploying
and with the standard tooling you know
you sort of have to pull in an entire
requirements.txt for example
and you know you might need many
requirements.text if you had different
requirements for different servers and
keeping them in sync is difficult
whereas a monorepo tool can just
slice out just the dependencies you
actually need
so
these are coded dependencies there's
another type of dependency that these
systems care about which is
the dependencies between units of work
and this is a static mapping that you
can construct at startup time before any
work is actually run
and what it is is just a set of rules
that knows how to transition between
inputs and outputs
and these rules form a graph that maps
the initial inputs which are things like
files on disk and the uh and sort of
state
two final outputs which is the goal that
the user requested so you could imagine
work just flowing through this graph
from
output to input to output to input
until you achieve a final result
and this is where the extensibility
comes in
you can in all of these systems because
everybody has very many organizations
have little custom scripts and build
steps you can plug them right in there
into this rule graph
and it
runs exactly the same as any other part
of any built-in rule
and this is where we get to the workflow
so those
based on the code dependencies plus the
task dependencies you can create a both
of which are static you can construct a
dynamic workflow at runtime and what
actually runs depends on invalidation on
what's available in the cache and so on
and the
important point here is that this
workflow
relies on no side effects causes no side
effects other than outputting the final
result
and it has no global state
and why is that important because that
is what enables concurrency and remote
execution right think about it if you
rely on local state or you rely on side
effects you cannot run um
you cannot take work and parcel it out
to a remote
system to a cluster um with any kind of
confidence
so
this explicitly modeled workflow
uh enables these four features which
if you remember from a few slides back
was
were exactly the features which speed up
your builds and make it scale as your
monorepo grows
so to sum up
i claim that monorepos are an effective
codebase architecture in many cases
that they require appropriate tooling
and fortunately this tooling exists
and i have been fortunate to have had a
hand in creating some of it
so uh thank you all so much for
listening i'm very happy to
take any questions uh and um you can
find us at this url uh
pants is uh part of a very friendly open
source community and we're always happy
to help out with any build questions you
may have
so thank you again